hey guys welcome back to the Evan and
Kaitlyn podcast the podcast where you
artists code in a grand simulation hi
guys
let's jump into things arrest you what's
happening I think that like life's just
been a lot recently
hour long has been a lot and our brains
are a little bit well it's like you know
just normal work and life stuff is
enough to juggle and then you have to
think about toilet paper shortages and
like prepping enough food for two weeks
yeah we've tried not to give in to any
of the panic we're not stockpiling
ridiculous amounts of stuff but it is
like we are doing a little bit you know
we're like prepping a couple extra
frozen meals which I typically do anyway
like I like you know we like making
meals that we can cook extra of and then
freeze stuff like pasta sauces or soups
and stews or like like taco filling and
things like that I think it's just
interesting that one thing I've realized
recently is is that like we kind of live
our life on like a very thin margin in
how much time we have to deal with
things that come up and buy very thin
margin I mean like there's no there's
not really any additional time to give
when stuff comes up and for anyone who
is maybe listening to this you know
weeks or months or years later it's
currently March of 2020 so all the
stuff you know just in case
someone's binge watching and they're
like what's going on what's happening
yeah yes that's that's what's going on
yeah this is hard it's hard to edit you
know I'm like trying to trying to edit a
video we just finished recording right
now but I'm also like you know I got
stuff to make that like pork chili verde
I should put and you go prep that pork
chili verde you know in like it's I
don't know I mean like we said we're not
we're not like panicking about it
anything crazy but we're trying to be
responsible I think there's another
aspect of it for me too
one thing well I think for both of us
one thing that's going on is as we keep
on making YouTube videos I feel like we
have to a certain degree started to
understand what makes for a good video
we don't it's not a guarantee but like I
feel like we have like the crack
combination of elements like materials
tools title thumbnail like concept it
has to like make you feel things it has
to maybe confuse you a little bit
there's like a bajillion things that are
like going into our calculations where
before we were just kind of like alright
we've been a while since we did a
woodworking video what's a woodworking
the thing we can do let's do an entryway
table it's like that was kind of
somewhat of our thought process but now
I feel like as we get somewhat of a
handle on what we feel would make a good
video for our channel coming up with
those ideas is becoming harder yeah is
this are you transitioning away from our
video idea for our next video done yeah
we don't which is really stressful we
really don't like not having our next
video idea figure it out because a lot
of times we have to order materials and
supplies and tools and sometimes you can
get it you know in two days sometimes
you can't get it in two days yeah yeah
and I know that like you know we often
don't talk about all of this because it
just like we worry that it's complaining
but I think it's just like a lot has
been getting to us and we like being
honest with you guys and so here we are
being honest I think another thing that
I realized is as we've stopped doing as
many videos we're not doing a video
every week we're kind of averaging like
two videos than a break two videos than
a break because we just don't have the
next video ready and we need to like
work at a pace that's reasonable for us
and related back to what you're talking
about about brainstorming and the ideas
we're choosing to do because we're
spending more time brainstorming to come
up with what we think is a better video
and we're not just rushing into it
that's part of
what leads to the videos being slightly
more spaced out yeah but that also means
that each video has more pressure on it
because we just don't want like ways to
video when we know that like if we think
long and hard enough we can come up with
that video idea that like is really
worth the 80 hours we put into it
instead of this thing oh this is one's
like a three star idea let's just do
that we have a ranking system for ideas
yeah one through five stars if it's not
a one star it's just gone like like one
is an okay idea that needs more work two
is like a little bit better three is
like in the running for is like we
definitely want to do it and five is
like we're doing it now right now yeah
so I think that that's that's kind of
how our idea ranking system works but
it's just it just seems like it's been a
lot are like to-do list is huge and yeah
the crown fire is having stuff on not
our next video plan it's just now we're
at like a place guys another thing that
I've been thinking about a lot which
basically I we did we didn't even do
that we didn't even do the intro the
best we didn't do an overview we didn't
say what topic we're talking about today
yeah the topic we're talking about is
how video games are like life or how
life is like a video or how life is like
a video game and it's been a topic
that's been on my mind a lot I think
because Katelyn handles the editing of
our main videos and I handle like the
running of our gaming channel the
majority of it and Katelyn helps out a
lot like talking with editors helping
them figure out how to tweak that it so
mostly yeah a lot of things but I kind
of have been putting a lot of thought
into what games we should play what
games make for good streams what has the
right balance where we can interact like
that like the game will prompt us to
interact and have fun moments that might
surprise us that like has a good enough
pace but also we can pause and interact
with the chat in a way that doesn't like
hurt the gameplay and everything like
that so there's just a lot of things
that balance kind of like as we've been
working on our main channel videos and
we've been refining
how to make those videos I've been kind
of working on like what the best
gamestream are how to play them how to
balance these three things that we get
from playing games we stream it live
with like two hundred and something
people then we upload the uncut where
people watch the whole thing and then
that gets turned into a highlight so
when we do it would like to be optimized
to the point where people watching it
live enjoy it
people who watch the entire recording
aren't bored by us just interacting with
the chat afterwards and we don't we are
not like just talking to the live
audience while interesting things are
happening that the editors will need to
edit to make the game good who knew
playing video games still so enjoyable
and I can't no more video games and
streams but it's just been like a lot to
balance and I think one thing that I've
been thinking about as I've been
thinking about these video games is how
they relate to life a lot and basically
I just wanted to chat with you about how
video games are like life and how life
is like video games and just like have a
little bit of a fun discussion about it
I don't really have a point I just want
to explore it and I want to bring up
some like interesting points that I
think are interesting at least and then
just get your thoughts I don't have a
point I just want to bring up some
interesting points lots of lots of small
points no no big like agenda that I'm
trying to like get to or anything like
that and I think that like as I've been
thinking about what makes a good video
game I've just been finding parallels to
life in a way like things that might
lead to a good video game also might be
things that lead to a good life yeah and
like how to play video games in a way
relates to things that I think might be
good ways to live your life in strange
ways so anyways like one thought that I
had is how in video games you need to be
challenged if video games are just a
100% easy it's it's you you lose some
things about life that are enjoyable you
lose some things about games that are
enjoyable enjoyable like if you play a
video game on full easy mode of all
cheats like one video game that that we
play that there's a lot of grinding
involved and grinding for those of you
guys who don't play video games too much
is like just putting in the time putting
in the effort and just putting in lots
of time so you get incremental rewards
more and more and more and I kind of see
a lot of that in Diablo where it's a
role-playing game where you're like a
digital character you start at level
zero and as you fight bad guys your
level increases you get more Skills you
get items you get loot you get all these
things that make you more powerful but
if you started at that powerful level
and you started at zero of the game yeah
it probably wouldn't be super fun cuz
you're just like oh and you just kill
everything nothing can hurt you like if
you started Diablo this game that we
like as like a really powerful super
cheated person then you would not enjoy
the game the the game is fun because
there's a struggle you you want
something you get rewarded with it and
the effort you're putting in and the
reward you get back is kind of like
what's fun about life or make in a way
yeah I mix your life yeah so I I think
like the parallels to life are for
example when you think of people who
never have to work a day in their lives
you know like they inherit money or
whatever it is like from the outside
that could look like it's just the most
awesome thing you don't have to work
yeah that sounds great but then a lot of
times those people end up kind of
depressed yeah you know because without
having to work for anything it feels
like there's no meaning that reminds you
of it there's a TED talk once
that was about like happiness is
relative so if you don't have strug
in life you don't really feel happiness
oh yeah like you comparison yeah you
need that contrast in order to like feel
it and it's I mean it's kind of like
that with the game too but I think I
think using the games as a structure but
relating it back to life is the more
interesting way to think about it I mean
there's this like one of the things that
made me think about it is I was
listening to a podcast or an audiobook
actually about the oil field and how
like the history of it there's all sorts
of things going on lots of shady moments
and everything and one of the the
stories that they told was of this oil
baron and his rich son who had like
millions of dollars and like they talked
about his life in the corruption that he
was part of and everything about like
when they were describing his life they
weren't trying to make the point that it
was a depressing life but like hearing
about his life and like the way he spent
his money and his time and you know how
he was always upset and never satisfied
it just it was so interesting because he
never had this struggle none of his
successes were really because of him
and it just it just seemed kind of it's
just seemed really depressing honestly
hearing about this like ultra rich
person's life who was like the son of a
dictator of a country like one that's
just a sad situation because there
shouldn't be dictators and that's a
whole other thing but like honestly this
guy's life I didn't feel anything but
like pity for this guy I don't know yeah
and this made me think about video games
if like you were you started a video
game and that's the only video game you
could play but you had all the cheat
codes enabled like how would that be fun
yeah they would be like a novelty of it
for a few minutes and then I'm bored
yeah another way I've thought about like
role-playing games and like Diablo and
how that relates to life is when Caitlyn
and I were starting our evident Caitlyn
brand and our business and everything
like that we decided that for an
extended period of time we were gonna
push beyond what was regular what was
normal for people to put in
okay and like our work and effort yeah
in terms of our work and effort that was
gonna be like our intense grind period
yeah I was like about we expected like a
year or two to like really get things
off the ground and and it was like two
years of hard grind then we had a little
period where things were a little more
calm and then it got harder again but
that's that's always gonna be it's never
just like a continuous slope there's
like little ups and downs on a trending
path yeah but like it made me think of
when you're playing like a game like
Diablo like a role-playing game where
when like you are level 5 or something
it's best to like fight against a level
5 bad guys but if you're a level 5 like
player like a sorcerer or whatever and
you're a fighting level 5 bad guys
you're only leveling up at a certain
pace but if you go like way outside of
your comfort zone way outside of where
you should be and you start battling
like level 10 lot faster dad guys you're
gonna grow a lot faster and I think that
that's kind of the situation we put
ourselves in we put ourselves like like
like growing as a person
you grow at a certain rate but if you
put yourself like way outside of your
comfort zone if you put yourself like if
you like there's one thing that I did a
lot I was like like accepting talks at
Convention so I was like yeah convention
let's let's give a speech there that's
something we've never done before I'm
sure we can figure that out
that was like us accepting like
difficulty that was much harder than we
were ready for so that we could grow a
lot faster and I feel like that's
something that we did a ton in our life
while we are starting evident eight-lane
and just like really made me think about
video games in a way I don't know if
there's a normal thing I'm I feel like a
weirdo relating them a lot but I kind of
well I mean even just using that talk
example so we were at about 40,000
subscribers when we gave our first talk
yeah and everyone else giving talks is
at in the like two hundred to two
million yeah two hundred thousand to two
million subscribers range so that kind
of shows like a very um
like concrete level differential level
yeah like differential yeah exactly yeah
it is interesting
um because like you said those are the
things that help you grow faster
whether it's like I mean for us business
and personal are very interconnected
um but you could apply it to both well I
think that the reason why I often use
video games in my mind to make sense of
life in a way is because life is really
complicated it's like there aren't any
rules there aren't any like like clear
definitions of how life works there's
some rules there's like don't murder
people
there are rules but like there's always
exceptions to all rules to you know do
murder people I don't know there are
situations where like in the world I
don't know I don't want to get into that
but like you know it's like like life is
really complicated and in video games
there are very strict rules everything
is based off of math everything is like
there are lots of best practices and
everything and I don't know
I like systems that make sense as an
engineer I like math I like rules
I like physics and in terms of like real
life things there aren't any of that
it's kind of like with YouTube there's
no rules there's no best practices I
mean there there are but then there are
the people breaking them yeah that are
killing it I would say there's no
guarantees there's no guarantees there's
there's rules there's best practices but
there's no guarantees but like like
people are saying longer videos are good
now but like also short videos are great
some people are saying put a ton of time
and effort and polish into your
thumbnails and other people are saying
no no no leave your thumbnails very raw
so it looks like there a screenshot and
of course it has to be something
interesting so it's like you can't just
like but I guess like for me it's I'm
thinking more broadly I'm thinking have
a good thumbnail hmm that's a that's a
rule or a best practice
or that would be a best practice a rule
would be like don't break Terms of
Service you know so like there are rules
and best practices but I think like they
are so broad and can be really vague
like make good content yeah and then as
soon as you try to get more specific
specific to something that would
actually be useful that's where what
you're saying comes in where there's
like a billion exceptions and a billion
different nested best practices yeah
that where like you can't just like pick
a path and follow it and there's no
guarantee but like other other games
that I've thought of and how they relate
to life another thing that I thought of
our real time strategy games and for
those of you non-gamers I'll explain it
real quick there's one of my favorite
types of games you you build a base and
most realtime strategy games you start
out with a little base you have your
main structure then you have like your
resource gathering people and then you
build more structures that let you
create little armed units and you move
them around them the map and usually the
objective is to destroy the other teams
base before they destroy yours
and it's really interesting because like
the big balance in those games is you
want to build up your base as soon as
you can so that you can make more units
faster and defend it against attacks but
also if you put all of your time and
effort into like just building up your
base the other person's gonna attack you
too soon and you won't be ready or if
you like it's just like there's a lot of
balancing in these realtime strategy
dancing like your offense and your
defense yeah and resource gathering your
versus your resource using and like
balancing like how much the research
technology versus just producing units
how like all of these things and I think
that I see a lot of parallels in
real-time strategy games to business
also like another example I thought of
is like you want to explore the map as
soon as possible and scout at what
opportunities and resources are around
you and what dangers there are and I
just think about like our business and
our evident katelyn business and how a
law
of those like similar thoughts happen to
us we're like well do we get the most
expensive camera right away or do we get
a cheap camera learn on it figure out
what is important for us to get in our
more expensive camera like Dooley just
start pumping out content that's just
like like volume or do we like put more
time into enhancing its quality you know
and there's a balancing act in all of
that everything comes at a cost because
everything is different balancing acts
and if you put more energy into one
you're taking away energy from the other
because they're like in direct
competition of each other yeah
I don't it's kind of interesting and
like I've always thought like another
thought that I've had around all these
thoughts that I have is like it's like
am i just justifying my obsession with
video games by finding parallels in life
no I think it's I think everyone tries
to make sense of life in various ways
yeah and I think this is a way that it
started it started with you but like it
you've brought me into it and I like
fully see it now and now we find like
parallels all the time so I I think you
know I think it was normal to want to
try to process things you're normal
you're super normal I love you
another type of game that I've thought
about a lot oh sorry I think before
because I think like you're kind of
rushing through game types but I think
the more interesting thing is to think
of well I was wanting to finish all the
game types then we could use all those
game types to talk about how they relate
to our life and how they relate to
people's lives in general and then we
came back like look through all of the
different game types and then like apply
it to life the last game that I kind of
thought about is adventure games like
Zelda you know you're you're an
adventurer there's story there's like
you're exploring and you're finding
details and you're solving puzzles and
how I thought about that is I
adventure games need to keep a certain
pace because if like the puzzles are too
hard you get frustrated and you don't
like the game I think that that kind of
is kind of similar to what you said
about the right yeah
no no there are PG RPG it's like too
hard it's too frustrating if it's too
easy it's too boring I think when it
comes to like pace it's more about is it
too much of the same thing so a lot of
adventure games there's fighting and
there's puzzles if you're doing fighting
fighting fighting fighting fighting and
there's not enough puzzles it might like
the fighting might start to get kind of
repetitive especially if there's only
limited bad guys and you're only doing
the same thing yeah yeah and vice versa
- like if you're just doing puzzles and
you want to like get to some action and
especially the puzzles are similar it
can get kind of like redundant yeah and
like the parallel that we've had in that
example - life is like how it's
interesting to mix up your life it's
interesting to like if you've been doing
the same job for a long period of time
you might be interested in changing jobs
if you've been doing the same like I
don't know some people don't get tired
of hobbies or sports they watch or
what-have-you but like all right I think
there's a lot of times in life or you've
been doing the same thing for a while
and you want to mix it up maybe you've
been not having a cat for your whole
life and you're like I don't know mix it
up and then you get a cat and that's a
great decision well maybe you've been
having one cat your whole life and
you're like I want to mix it up and you
get whole bunch of cats wait yet 200
okay so those are the main types of
games that I thought of and I even
looked like right before this podcast I
was looking through all the different
types of games there are and I just
didn't see that many parallels in the
other games this is like three kind of
Whitely a popsicle yeah like I wasn't
able to find too many parallels in life
in fighting games when you're fighting
someone you need to block and punch I
guess maybe it depends on your life we
don't do much much physical fighting
yeah or like platformers like Mario and
stuff like I mean I do enjoy jumping I
do
and going from left to right like I
wasn't like in a lot of the other types
of games I wasn't able to find too many
like gleam life lessons from who you
know it would be one interesting thing
to look at and this you mostly find in
kind of like open-world games which can
or like different different levels of
open-world Ness because there are some
games like Minecraft that is 100% open
yes there's some rules but it's not
telling you do this first and then do
this and then do that and then there's
some games like you know Zelda even
though I know like breath of the wild it
was a little bit more open but like past
two zelda games where it's like you do
this temple and then you do this temple
and then you do this temple and there's
order it won't let you go out of order
and then there are things that are kind
of in-between like when we played The
Last of Us it's a zombie game it is
guiding you but it doesn't feel like
it's guiding you like you feel like
you're choosing to go down this path in
the forest but actually there's just a
lot of like psychological tricks that
they have used on you to make you choose
that path and if you really tried to
just like decent rarey
yeah like it wouldn't work but like it
you feel like you're choosing your own
way yeah and that would be interesting
like it's kind of like when you have
your own business there's no one telling
you like you got to do this and then you
got to do this and then you got to do
this I think that that shows like
personality is like certain people like
certain types of games certain people
like like strong direction and they know
what to do they do it they get the
objective they get that accomplishment
where it says check move on to the next
thing and some people like the
open-world games like Minecraft that can
be or an open world life open world life
yeah like you know and and that mainly
one example is the two of us which are
like completely open world we can do
whatever we want wait we can do whatever
we want what do we want to do yeah let's
just let's just mind sand because we
never know what we're gonna need
yes that would be another it's so easy
to mix like the life and videogame
analogies you know I was just talking
about life and you're talking my video
games it happens yeah but it's kind of
like Minecraft one reason why I think
that we like it so much is this a mix of
a lot of our genres there are like
quests that we give ourselves like let's
find something ships and sunken treasure
or there's like Base building which we
like or there's like you know developing
your character and grinding and getting
gear getting that diamond armor getting
that enchanted sword and everything yeah
I don't know like a good fit I don't
know where I was going with that in
terms of the point yeah but I think the
interesting thing is how like those
different styles also apply to life I'm
trying to think of one that is like the
middle style where it feels kind of open
but there are goals and there are oh
like a parallel between games like that
and life I mean because maybe what we're
doing is actually that we think that we
have the choice that really were being
guided by the system yeah I'm social
media yeah responsibilities as a
business to like make money make money
yeah and pay our bills yeah you're right
it's not a completely open source
because they're like open world because
if it was completely open world and we
could do literally whatever we wanted to
without any pressures on us then yeah we
would maybe live our lives a little bit
differently would make less videos
probably I think yeah we would just put
less stress on ourselves that's
stressful
I think we'd still be doing a similar
like similar things just like at a
slower pace well I guess it's like kind
of like in Minecraft
there's the hunger system so that's like
a system in place that forces you to do
certain things regularly
you know or like system we are playing
this like scary adventure game called
the forest where like you have hunger
you have thirst you I can get too cold
if you swim in like rivers at night and
you need a huddle by a fire like like so
so like but at the same time we can go
wherever we want
and you know have whatever adventures we
want but like I think life is kind of
like video games just like that you know
it's like you have certain restrictions
on your life that you have to like be
responsible and take care of but I don't
know interesting I think that one thing
that's I always had interesting again
okay one thing I noticed while we've
been talking about games and how I
related to life and everything like that
is I think that I have been doing the
things like this for a long time with
everything not just like games but also
books like when I read books and when I
like this has been for a long time I've
always thought about like can I gain any
life lessons from this book I know it's
weird
and I haven't doing that since I was
like young like yeah before I was like
10 or something like that it always like
look at characters that I liked and say
like what did I like about that person
and why did I not like this person and
do I want to be like either of them and
like what type of person do I want to be
and I've been thinking about that for
like people that meet people I like
encountering books and stories and I've
always like thought that like we aren't
static as people and we can change and
we can change our lives and since we can
change as people and we can change our
lives what type of person do I want to
be in what type of life do I want to
live and that's kind of like a big
question to tackle and I'm still doing
it yeah you were definitely more
introspective than the average kid that
young I definitely had similar thoughts
I think like they probably started
hitting me more around middle school mhm
going kind of off topic but I think like
one well I mean I'm I'm sure that a lot
of people have similar thoughts but I
think personally for me one reason I
would often like very actively have
those kind of thoughts and it wasn't so
much like oh like it wasn't so much
reacting off of characters before you
know exactly but I think because we both
moved a lot mm-hmm
every time you move
it's an opportunity to reinvent yourself
it's like new chapters in the game yeah
where it's like new stages like a new
game like a new game yeah it's a new
game it's like it's like starting a new
character in jobless it's like starting
a new character that's it
you can like change your outfit you can
change your class you can change like
what types of skills you're pursuing
mm-hmm yeah so all of a sudden I just
started shopping a hot topic coordinated
correspondent with a move yeah yeah
that's so that's so interesting starting
a new character yeah shake us would be
one benefit of moving a lot because I
think like you can of course make
changes to yourself without going
through a drastic change of location but
I do think it's it's maybe harder when
your surroundings aren't changing to
change yourself also yeah it is like it
is like starting a new character I'm
thinking of all those like the parallels
in might have I don't want to say them
all because they're kind of obvious and
everything but you can like you know
instead of going down the path of
learning all the fire moves I smooth
Kaitlyn and I whenever we play
role-playing games
we're both wizards oh yeah those are our
favorite classes so we're not like we're
not like let's go down the rage path
let's go down the archer path row like
what elemental powers do we want this
time around Rou yeah well I think that
that the main ways I think that all of
these thoughts can apply to like people
in general and everything is like maybe
we could like wrap it up into like life
lessons like you pulled from video games
that could be widely applicable
potentially or might like spark ideas
okay one if you want to grow faster and
you feel comfortable with that get
outside of your comfort zone
aka get outside your character level get
outside of your character level yeah and
I think that that really does lead to
like very increased like development
with your skills with like your like
who you are like you you'll learn what
you like and what you don't like like if
you live the same life all the time
that's totally cool like some people
don't like pushing and-and-and rapid
change and what-have-you but if you live
your same life and you don't go to that
trivia night and meet new people if you
don't quit your job for that what other
job that you've been super excited about
that long for the longest time if you
don't go up to that girl that you've
been crushing on for the longest time
and like ask her for her number or
something how do you do these days like
message someone on like tick tock or
something like you I like your style
alright you slide into the D and fight
into the DMS yeah it's been a while
since I dated well back when we were
dating
there was like Facebook yeah and you
this like Instagram around yet I don't
know like nah not like when we were
dating but like when we were like
previously dating yeah yeah also like
you had my number and we were friends on
Facebook and we had been friends
situation is like very non-standard this
is like become friends for four years
five years and then one day confess your
feelings for each other yeah totally
totally standard yeah okay so that's
that's a good yeah yeah push yourself
outside of your general comfort zone
you'll grow faster and you'll etcetera
etc I think idea too is continual
balancing I think that's like kind of
from the real-time strategy because
there is no like single balance like as
you're exploring and scoping the map you
see that yeah there's a whole bunch of
people coming your way like oh I need to
put a whole bunch of time resources into
defenses you know or if you don't see
them coming you can say like oh I can
upgrade my
nology a little one way to think about
that that it's kind of its kind of like
a broad view maybe is like being
proactive versus reactive yeah in your
life because if you're constantly like
if if you're being proactive and you
ignore things that you might need to be
reactive to that could be bad but if
you're only reactive then you're like
like constantly battling without ever
like reaping any long-term gains yes I
think that's less than three actually so
like put outside your comfort zone one
be proactive versus reactive I think
that's really good but kind of what I
was thinking is like continually
readjust you know what I mean like like
in December when ad rates are up for us
and we're getting a ton of sponsors
where we might do more videos you know
like we might just that Bally haven't
yet do a might well like like like you
know like adjust that balance and then
in January where ad rates are lower in
there art is in these boxes less videos
you know so but like continually be
balancing and then like you know like be
proactive versus reactive I think that's
like another thing but also like you
know in terms of the balancing for us in
particular and for for you know people
in general like look at your life and
see how you need to rebalance it like we
are continually looking at our like our
lives and really are we burning out are
we in the process of like completely
losing what we like love about our work
because we'd never want to get to that
point and we say okay we need to pull
back on videos or like let's pull back
on video games because like that's been
taking it away from like our life and in
other ways or like has it been a year
since we saw our friends yes it has we
should probably message our friends and
you know keep those relationships alive
you know but like continually
rebalancing I think is is one lesson
yeah I mean we're particularly we're
very protective of the situation where
and the enjoyment we get from the
situation we're in and the situation I
mean like like you know being able to
work together and make videos and play
video games and you know make podcasts
and all these different things that we
do like we really love it and so we're
super protective of it so we analyze it
a lot yeah
lesson four play To Your Strengths and
compliment other people's strengths
that's kind of like a lesson from like
real time sorry
role-playing games like I know Caitlin
and I like both like being mages every
time because they're fun and we just
blast things apart but like a more ideal
combination might be like a mage and a
paladin because like as a paladin I
could be upfront taking damage and
healing Caitlyn and she could be like
the main damage DPS output her well I
would say even when we are both mages
usually one of us will do range and one
of us will do like close yeah combat so
we still do like you know divide and and
you know specialize and kind of like
that's what we've done with our business
where it's the balance we've developed
has I kind of naturally developed as
Caitlyn did editing like I would look at
our to-do list and see what I can do
wall Caitlyn's editing so I like you
know took on some responsibilities and
then well I'm designing things
Caitlyn looks at to-do list and like
over time I just like started repeatedly
doing some things in Caitlyn side
repeatedly doing something this we both
developed into specialists of what we do
and so we kind of like split tasks
divide and conquer and play to each
other's strengths in like a really good
way and that naturally evolved I'm not
really sure where I'm going with that
dividing divide and conquer play to your
strengths yeah that's lesson four of an
unknown amount of an unknown amount of
lessons we have gained from video games
choosing games that are not too hard not
too easy that probably is just still
relating back to push yourself outside
your comfort zone
think like it's maybe it think it's
related but I think it's kind of like
know yourself and know what level of
challenge you are cool with and know
that like you probably need some level
of challenge in order to like feel more
success like because I think that the
the thought is like man I wish I could
just like you know be on my phone all
day or watch movies all day and not
really do anything and still not have to
worry about money and like man that
would be the life but is that the point
of life just to have everything easy and
just to like indulge forever yeah I
don't know I mean I don't I don't think
so
not for us in particular for some people
you know for some people may be anyone's
choice in life I think it's like know
yourself and don't just assume that that
is like the happiest okay so that's rule
that's rule 5 and it's linked to one in
a way like you keep like putting
yourselves outside your comfort zone
really helps you grow but also like be
aware of the balance between easy mode
and hard mode and what each brings
because easy mode is easier it is more
chill but like have you have I'm sure
that like there everyone who's listening
has had a weekend where he just binge
watch videos all day every day for the
whole weekend and have like two days we
just do nothing except for like binge
watch a show or something
mm-hmm we had one day like that four
years ago but I think that like at the
end of that day I think something that
we we think of is like do we feel good
about that time and sometimes it's yes
but sometimes it's no I don't know and
and depending on what type of person you
are it'll more likely to be yes or no
yeah are we
stretching now well I think that kind of
like might be a good place to end it we
have like four five life lessons gained
from video games that's that's a good
title maybe we should have structured
this podcast more like that I don't know
our babies our brains were only so
functioning when we do this podcast it's
like usually we record the podcast like
a little bit earlier at Saturday we're
publishing this in two days like oh we
got to do the fuck yeah it's almost
dinnertime yeah and I think that this is
another reason why we are considering
like well we have pulled back on the
amount of content we're putting out and
why we are constantly re-evaluating
things as a business and as people
because we want to be able to make the
best content that we have or we can and
not saying that this isn't good content
not that I'm not proud of this I I like
this idea I've been wanting to talk to
you about these concepts for a while but
like you know if we had of had a little
bit more time hadn't of like maybe if we
had a put more structure into it if we
hadn't didn't bring that all week
because like everything everything cuz
everything is not getting enough sleep
and everything but that's why I like I
don't know I don't really know where I
was going with this but one of the
things we are considering in the future
is continually readjusting our
difficulty setting is readjusting our
balance of like output and quad quantity
and quality but like we might and
relating back like like okay so like we
mentioned we've pulled back in the past
few months to doing like two videos and
then we'll take good buffer and two
videos and then we'll take a buffer
before that it was three videos a buffer
three videos of ever before that we were
just doing a video every single week and
and before that there was some months
where we would do five or six videos and
during those times like like when we
push a you know assuming all other
things are equal like let's say our past
five videos instead
them fitting into two months if they if
all that was fit into one month yeah our
channel what our numbers would be better
we would be making more income you know
like we would be a quote unquote
leveling up faster um but that's not
always the priority and it's not always
like a long-term strategy yeah yeah
which is why now we're good we're like
trying to work more closely to our skill
level and hot-fudge ourselves too too
much because we don't want to burn out
well but also like realtime strategy
games like like like right now we have
like a really awesome base with evan and
caitlyn main channel but like we're
working on our second base that's in a
really interesting strategic position
and it's very small it's not super
powerful yet but like it's really well
positioned and I see huge potential for
that in the future how much resources do
we run yeah our main channel to the gate
and put them to the gaming channel to
feed it yeah yeah I don't know but uh
yeah that's another balance that we have
going on anyways don't worry about us
we're totally fine I know that we kind
of rambled a lot about a little I don't
know how things are like difficult and
and everything but we're we're good
though like we're yeah I'm so excited to
like finish this edit that I'm working
on because like the video that's coming
out this week I think you guys are
really gonna like we've been really
enjoying the gaming channel and like we
just found a new game that we're super
excited about playing in like an hour to
do list is going down and we are gonna
like adjust the difficulty setting of
our game it does take a while for that
setting to kick in because we do
schedule like two or two three months
out but like we'll get through this and
we are gonna keep on like tweaking our
lives until it is how you like it then
we're just gonna keep on tweaking it
alright I think it's time for a thing of
the week
my thing of the week is the go XLR I
know I talk about podcasts and streaming
things a lot on this podcast but it's
another soundboard
how many sound boards are we up to sound
devices we're up to three so one mix one
hacks is all the game sounds one mixes
are two voices and the go XLR like mixes
the computer and the stream and all of
that so it's just another interesting
device I think it'd be good for a single
person podcast or single person streamer
I think that's like a really it's a
really good device for that it has a lot
of its advanced features but I'm still
very much figuring out it has a really
great auto-tune squirrel mode which I
enjoy that's a really great demon anyway
it's like I originally got it because I
wanted to tweak our voices live while
we're streaming and it has a lot of
those effects but also it's also been
really nice because it's it has a
software element to you can do like
noise gates you can tweak all the mics
you can do equalizers compressors like
the aesir's there's like all you can do
sampling you can route things in all
sorts of different ways and it's just
like it's a lot it's a little bit
intimidating at the same time but uh
it's it's something that I'm excited to
like keep on messing with and figuring
out and leveling up our technology to
the next level yeah anyways what's your
what's your thing of the week toilet
paper I kid my thing of the week this is
not a new video but it is a video that
we are in so you guys know at this point
I don't know by the time this podcast
comes out how much we will have shared
but we have shared that we're doing a
project with our air cannon and it's a
cannon that we built for a collab so
it's never been on our channel before
but we built it for a collab with the
modern rogue and in that video we bust
out our original cannon in the propane
cannon and this solenoid
a solenoid triggered air cannon and we
try to destroy things and realize how
tough pumpkins are pumpkins are very
tough always use watermelons if you're
going for a dramatic watermelons are
great
pumpkins are so tough so tough this was
around Halloween yeah
hence all the pumpkins yeah so I was
like last it was a November 2018 yeah
but I think we filmed it around
Halloween yeah somewhere around there
anyways yet modern rogues channel the
video title is building a solenoid
trigger air cannon will link to it in
our description well guys thanks for
tuning in to another podcast episode I
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
I hope you're the settings of your game
are set properly that is not too
difficult that you're exploring an
interesting area of life that but know
that you can change those settings or
switch games yeah start a new save your
adventure awaits and look for to see you
next time